- Casey Becker was born sometime
around 1979 or 1980. She seems
to be the only child in her family. Casey
was a fan of horror movies, just like you,
the viewer! I think this was an intentional
choice. If audiences could relate to Casey,
they too could feel the fear that she feels.
Her favorite horror movie is Halloween,
which also has to be intentional, since
Halloween is one of the most popular horror
movies. She also likes the first Nightmare
on Elm Street but thinks the rest suck.
Casey attends Woodsboro High School where she
had English class first period with Mrs. Tate.
At some point she has a short relationship
with her classmate Stu Macher. Not much is
known about their time together. I’m not sure if
she became interested in horror as a result of
their relationship, or if their relationship was
the result of their shared interest in horror.
I’m gonna go with the latter, because she seems
to still love horror after moving on from him.
Casey is not the most loyal girlfriend, she
always seems to be moving onto the next boy,
so she dumps Stu to get together with
Steve Orth, who, according to her,
is big, plays football and will kick the sh*t
out of you. He doesn’t look that big to me,
but he does have a letterman jacket, so I’m
inclined to believe he really does play football.
One night in October 1996, Casey has plans
to watch a couple of scary movies with Steve
but she receives a call that changes her
plans. To learn who really killed Casey,
stick around to the end of this video.
This video is sponsored by Audible.
(metal music)
Welcome to Horror History. Go ahead and
just type your name into the comments,
because… I want to know who I’m looking at.
In today’s lesson, I’ll be analyzing the
first Scream victim… not chronologically,
I believe that honor goes to Maureen Prescott…
but the first victim of the first movie
Ms. Casey Becker. Despite only appearing
in one sequence, Casey is easily one of
the most iconic Scream characters. Go to
a screening and you’ll see countless women
dressed up in white pullovers and blonde bob
cuts. Bonus points if she’s covered in blood.
Casey’s psychological reaction
to her stalkers is interesting,
so let’s take it back to that fateful night.
(mysterious music)
It is a foggy October night when Casey
is preparing for an evening of horror
flicks with her boyfriend. She receives
a phone call from an unknown caller and
lets him know it’s a wrong number. Casey is
dressed in all white, or at least near white,
from her bleach blond hair to her light faded
jeans. She represents a blank canvas that any
horror fan could project themselves onto.
As a blank canvas, she’s almost tempting
the killer to do a little painting. A little
splatter painting in red, to be more specific.
The mystery caller calls back to talk, and
she’s amused, but hangs up on him to start
some popcorn on the stove. Since Scream is a genre
commentary in the form of an actual horror movie,
it makes sense that Casey is preparing some
popcorn at the beginning, it’s exactly where
we might have been a couple minutes ago before
we started watching Scream, so when she gets
into trouble, it subconsciously put us on
edge as well -- it makes us share her fear.
We even see the VHS player’s blue screen on her
TV, which if you don’t remember or aren’t old
enough, is what you saw before putting
a tape in. This makes us feel as if we,
the audience, and Casey are both going into
a horror movie. The mystery man calls again,
and now she’s genuinely curious about who it is.
I think she most likely believes that someone
she knows is messing with her, so she humors
him and tells him about her evening plans.
- [Casey] I’m getting ready to watch a video.
- [Caller] Really? What?
-  Oh just some scary movie.
- [Caller] You like scary movies?
- Uh-huh.
- [Caller] What’s your favorite scary movie?
- We can see during this interaction, she’s
smiling. She’s amused by this mysterious caller
and she’s kind of flirting with him. She tells
him her favorite is Halloween, and guesses that
his might be A Nightmare on Elm St. He asks if
she’s got a boyfriend and she lies and says no.
One of the most well-known and longstanding
tropes in horror is the idea that promiscuity
can lead to death. We don’t see anything graphic
here, but we do eventually learn that she lied
about being single. Since Casey was most likely
targeted by Stu as revenge for their break-up,
her infidelity serves as the offense
that earns her the spot as first target
in the movie. When she asks why he
wants to know her name, he says…
- Because I want to know who I’m looking at.
- This gets her spooked and we can see her attitude
change. She gives him the cold shoulder and hangs
up. When he calls a fourth time, she’s really
getting scared; we can hear it in her voice like
she’s about to cry. This is when her defensive
instincts kick in. When the caller rings her a
fifth time, she raises her voice to try to
intimidate him, but he just yells over her,
threatening to gut her like a fish if she hangs
up on him again. This is not her getting annoyed,
this is her using an artificial sense of anger
to cover up what she’s really feeling: fear.
You can tell by what she does next, she leaves her
burning popcorn behind to go lock all the doors.
Her response is interesting, because up to this
point, she has no proof that this unknown caller
is even telling the truth. At this point, it could
be a prank call by someone miles and miles away,
so Casey’s reaction shows how insecure she really
is. Maybe the same kind of insecure that goes from
one boyfriend to the next with no gap in-between.
She threatens to call the police, but the voice on
the phone tells her that they’d never make
it in time. This is the first confirmation
that her caller maybe knows where she is
and this is where the tears start flowing.
- [Casey] What do you want?
- [Caller] To see what your insides look like.
- Next, the doorbell rings, and I think for
the first time, her fear is justified,
because now we at least know that
there is someone outside her house,
though we don’t yet know for sure that
it’s her creepy caller. She yells out,
- WHO’S THERE?
- And as she’s grabbing the phone again to call
the police, the caller calls back to scold her,
saying you should never yell ‘who’s there’
in a horror movie. Now it’s almost 100%
confirmed that the person she’s been speaking
with is outside her house. The killers could
have started with the doorbell, but it wouldn’t
have been as effective as torturing her through
the slow realization that the strange voice on
the other end of the line is no distant stranger.
(huge impact)
Scream was directed by Wes Craven, the
same man who brought us A Nightmare on
Elm St and The People Under The Stairs. You can
learn more about Wes Craven in his biography,
which is available for listening on Audible.
Audible offers an incredible
selection of audiobooks across
every genre — including horror. You’ll also
discover exclusive Audible Originals from
top celebrities, renowned experts,
and exciting new voices in audio.
It's a new year. You've probably got some
new resolutions, some new goals, right?
Whether it's learning a new skill, making
a lifestyle change or just reading as many
scary stories as possible, there is probably an
Audible title that can help you with that goal.
Members get a free title every
month, for keeps. Of course,
podcasts are just free. I'm gonna keep you
guys posted on what I'm reading this year,
so for the Audible members in my audience we'll
have a little audio book club every now and then.
You guys can leave a comment and let me know
what you're listening to. If you want to be a
part of this exclusive club all you gotta do is
go to “Visit Audible dot com slash czsworld or
text czsworld to 500-500. You'll find that link in
the description. Audible dot com slash CZsWorld.
(scary music)
Casey’s evening continues to get worse
as her options for survival dwindle.
She screams over the phone that her
boyfriend will arrive any second.
- [Casey] He’s big and he plays football and
he’ll kick the sh*t out of you!
- That’s one of the best lines ever in terms
of acting, I get goosebumps every time.
- [Caller] Ooh I’m getting scared. Shaking in my
boots. His name wouldn’t be… Steve would it?
- He instructs her to find Steve bloodied up
and tied to a patio chair, and her first
instinct is to go out and help him, but
the voice on the phone advises against it.
She’s forced to agree to play a game to save
Steve’s life, and the game is horror movie
trivia. She gets the first question correct, a
warm up question about the killer in Halloween,
despite freezing up at first in her hysteria.
The second question asks for the name of the
killer in Friday the 13th, to which she
quickly shouts "Jason", which he deems
incorrect because Mrs. Voorhees is technically
the killer in the original Friday the 13th.
However, I feel like this isn’t really
a fair question. He asked her to name
the killer in Friday the 13th. He did not
say the movie Friday the 13th. He just said
Friday the 13th. Friday the 13th
is also the name of the franchise,
and I’d say that Jason is the killer
of Friday the 13th the franchise.
Casey is not given time to
make this argument though,
and she’s forced to watch Steve brutally get
taken out. The third and final question asks:
- [Caller] What door am I at?
- Strangely, now that we know that there were
two killers, there’s a good chance she would
have been technically correct if she had
just answered. I’m guessing one of them
probably would have been posted at each door,
but whatever answer she gave, the opposite door
would be busted down. This would be their way
of ensuring she got that last question wrong.
A fellow creator named Zack Cherry
actually did this really cool video
where he mapped Billy and Stu’s hypothetical
positions outside the house throughout
the entire scene to try to answer that
question: who actually ended her life?
- [Zack C] We have to have both of the killers on
either side of the house. If they were both
on one side as people have suggested then
people could easily run out the opposite door
not knowing where they are… There is no right
answer obviously cause they’re each at one door.
- [Zac M] But Casey refuses to answer the final question,
which makes sense, because answering the questions
didn’t work in her favor before, and now she’s trying out
a new tactic. As a result, the killer at the
back door, which is most likely Stu, throws
a chair through and breaks into the house,
sending Casey running to the kitchen to arm
herself with a knife. She actually sees Ghostface
passing through and most likely heading to
the front door to let his accomplice in.
I think this shows that despite her shortcomings
in trivia, her next move is kind of intelligent.
Her attackers have made it very clear to her that
this is a horror movie and she is their victim.
A typical horror movie victim would probably
run out the front door, where there would have
been someone waiting for her, but she doesn’t do
that, she stays in the house. She’s subverting
their expectations of what goes on in a horror
movie. This is a preview of things to come for us
as the audience of Scream, a movie that
constantly challenges the status quo of the genre.
Casey sees her parents’ car approaching and she
sees Ghostface skulking around in the kitchen. In
the Zack Cherry video, he suggests that Billy went
upstairs and this is Stu searching the kitchen.
I agree with most of his version of the events,
but here’s the thing. His entire thesis relies
on the idea that when Stu goes to the front
door, he lets Billy in, which we know, because
when Casey’s parents get back, the door is left
open, and then Billy goes up and Stu stays down.
We never see this on camera. I feel like they
just as easily could have done the opposite:
Stu could have gone up and Billy could have
stayed down. So from a positioning standpoint,
it’s basically 50-50 on who the killer is. I’m
also not convinced that either of them even goes
upstairs, because after she sees this, the next
time she looks into the house, she sees this:
Ghostface with his back to the window, and then
he suddenly whips around and spots her. To me,
this looks more like one of them was turned away
from the window to talk to the other, and when
Casey appeared at the window, she was spotted, and then the other one said something along the lines
of “behind you” and that’s what caused this guy
by the window to spin around so quickly like that.
But CZ! This is an analysis of Casey
Becker, why are you analyzing Ghostface??
Because what happens next changes
how I look at Casey's final moments.
After being spotted she runs out of the house
barefoot, but Ghostface quickly catches her,
sticks a knife through her chest
and proceeds to strangle her.
Still she manages to fight back by kicking him
off of her. It's actually really impressive,
both Stu and Billy are over 6 feet tall
to her 5'4" and she sends him flying back.
Just then, Casey's parents are returning home, but
in a Halloween II moment, she isn't able to call
out to them, but I think this has more to do with
her vocal cord being damaged when she was choked.
They go inside and she struggles
to get to the front porch,
where her attacker pins her down. At this
point she knows she has no chance to survive,
so instead of fighting back with the last of
her energy, she reaches up to remove the mask.
I think she knows this wasn't a random attack,
because at this point it's pretty clear that it
was someone who is familiar with her house and
it's layout, and somewhat familiar with her,
enough to know she would be home alone
and her boyfriend was on the way over.
So she might as well learn who was after her
before it's all over. To satisfy her curiosity.
A lot is made of her reaction to seeing the
face. To me, this is not a face of surprise,
but one of recognition. I believe Stu is the
one to deal the finishing blow. You can map out
their routes through the house or analyze her
expression all you want, but to me, it always
had to be Stu who would have wanted dibs to get
revenge on his disloyal ex-girlfriend -- the girl
he most likely spent nights enjoying horror
movies with would become the victim of one.
She actually doesn't die right away
when he stabs her on the porch,
so her mom goes inside and actually
hears Casey die over the phone.
- [Mrs. Becker] Oh my God,  I can hear her!
(Casey moaning)
- [Stu] Tree!
(busy signal)
- It was kind of a missed opportunity actually. If
she had just said the name of her killer when she
heard her Mom's voice on the phone, the police
could have focused their investigation much more.
Casey’s corpse is gutted and hung
up in a tree. Five years later
and I'm still not allowed to show
that kind of imagery on YouTube.
Casey’s death leaves behind a legacy. She
becomes a sort of an icon of the Woodboro
murders. Her death scene would be fictionalized
as the opening of the movie Stab in 1998,
which is based on the events in Woodsboro.
In 2010, Casey's story would be adapted to
the big screen again in Stab 6, which is more
loosely inspired by the end of Ms. Becker's life.
Scream is iconic because of its ability
to use classic slasher movies as the basis
for the tropes that it satirizes.
Drew Barrymore, who plays Casey,
was the biggest name talent on the film. The
movie poster is literally just her face, yet,
she’s barely in the movie. This makes
her early death much more shocking.
It’s basically the same trick
pulled by Alfred Hitchcock when he,
spoiler alert for a 60 year old movie, killed
Janet Leigh very early on his 1960 film Psycho.
There are also some parallels
to Halloween, where two unnamed
parents return from a night out to find
their teen daughter stabbed to death.
Remember, Halloween is the movie that
is most heavily riffed on in Scream,
it's the film they all watch at the party, and
many if it's tropes play out during that party.
Drew Barrymore reprised her role in 2020…
sort of… for a short on YouTube about
what it would be like if she never died.
She looks as if she’s aged like a couple years
maybe. If they ever show more of that night in a
future Scream movie or something, I bet she could
just step right in and play the teenage Casey.
Casey Becker was a horror fan who found herself
in the shoes of one of her scream queens.
I mean, she wasn't wearing shoes, but you
get the idea. Her loose attachment in her
romantic relationships was a sign of her
personal insecurity, and it also probably
got her targeted as the first in a line of
teenagers to meet their fate in Woodsboro.
Let me know in the comments what other Scream
characters you'd like to see covered here on
Horror History. There's definitely more Scream in
the pipeline so remember to subscribe to CZsWorld
or I’ll gut you like a fish. And I'll see you
in the next one. Assuming we both survive.
Get vaccinated, it's easy.
(dance music)